i gotta be honest
even though i absolutely love emotional
storytelling
it actually takes quite a bit to make me
tear up when reading or watching
something
and so the fact that this scene made me
bawl my eyes out with a really weird
mixture of feelings
says a lot about the impact that the
ming's furiously loyal sacrifice on zou
had in the story
and so while i would personally say that
post timeskip one piece
at least so far has had significantly
fewer powerful and iconic moments than
before the time skip
this one here easily can compete with
them
thus i think it's no wonder that we have
to talk about chapter 816
and episode 767 in our the iconic scene
analysis series
trademark so make yourself comfortable
with some hot coffee
grab some tissues and let's analyze one
of the two
biggest plot twists in the story of one
piece so far
oh yeah and if you haven't done so
already make sure to subscribe to the
channel
it's free and you get updates on any of
my future videos
[Music]
after witnessing all the horrors that
jack one of the commanders of kaido
had dealt to the minks and the city in
his search for ryzo
one of the main antagonists of the yonko
frankie
robin and brooke learned that kinemon
and conjuro
have already landed on the island and
met with momonosuke
since all the minks have sworn under
torture
pain and death that there is no samurai
rhizo hidden on their islands
the straw hats fear that their arrival
will trigger and enrage the minks who
apparently have suffered through
all these atrocities for some samurai
they don't even know
however the wano samurai have already
been noticed
and both inurashi as well as nekomamushi
the two
rulers of the minks that have been
facing off with jack have
already mobilized their troops in search
for them
at the whale forest the remaining straw
hats together with a confused luffy
try to find kinamon enchondro to keep
them from encountering any minks
finally all four parties approach each
other
when nekomamushi and inurashi that have
hated and
avoided each other for years meet each
other the tension between the two
immediately rises the straw hats
meanwhile manage to knock kingdom on at
the others out of view before they can
get spotted
as they witness the two main leaders
exchanging taunts
all of this is accompanied by flashbacks
of their torture through the beast
pirates
as they're put up on crucifixes after
jack used one of caesar's chemical
weapons
to render all of the minks paralyzed and
unable to fight back
in the heat of their argument both
nakomamushi and inurashi draw their
weapons
but before they can start fighting
seriously
kinemon steps up and shouts at them to
stop
when the minks recognize the samurai the
straw hats expect the worst and
try to convince kinemon to flee with
momo and kanjo by his side however
kinemon proclaims himself as a samurai
of wano
who's on the look for his comrade rhizo
and at the peak of the tension
suddenly all of the minks kneel down and
reveal that
rhizo is in fact safe to the absolute
shock of the crew
they explained that the kozuki and the
mings have had a very old and deep going
connection
and that they would never sell out a
friend even
if it meant death
i told you guys to get some tissues damn
now there are actually a number of
reasons why this moment
works so incredibly well on a basic
level the
basic story beats of this scene are
actually quite similar to the first
video of the series
zorro taking on luffy's pain on thriller
bark
the focus of both scenes lies on a
fierce display of loyalty in the face of
pain
and possibly even death it's the
ultimate display of honor and altruism
with no hopes or expectations of gaining
anything yourself
but a clear conscience just as zorro
is willing to end his own life and dream
for luffy's sake
the entire mink tribe is prepared to
sacrifice
their entire culture and race for one
single samurai one might even say that
they'd be willing to give
an arm and a leg for friends
now even though this is quite
ideological
it nonetheless works perfectly because
oda has put in the necessary narrative
groundwork and foreshadowing
to make both moments feel absolutely
natural
and organic for these characters through
this moment
oda characterizes the minks not only as
a tribe of powerful fighters
but also as a nation that never even
thought for a single moment
about betraying their allies
[Music]
as we now know there was no traitor
amongst them
all of them knew that ryzer was there
and they even had to restrain him to
keep him from joining the fight and
being caught
and for so many chapters oda made us
believe that he really
wasn't there and we see them being
tortured
poisoned and suffering for days for what
seemed like
no good reason at all at the time surely
no one would be willing to lose a limb
or
even their life for some random samurai
and even if they did surely at least
some or
one of them would put their lives or the
lives of their loved ones
first but no they all
suffered through all of it gladly which
makes the minks not only the most
loyal but also the most kind-hearted
race in the story
and all of this of course becomes even
more powerful
in the context of odin and his backstory
with the retainers
his ability to inspire this level of
commitment
and determination in his retainers as
well as the tragic backstory for
all of them give this moment an even
more powerful feeling on a re-read
than it already had in the first place a
truly
inspirational scene
now the thing that amplifies this
already
powerful theme of loyalty and sacrifice
even more
and that differentiates it from the
zorro moments is
the major plot twist that oda pulls with
the reveal of rhizo's safety
i personally think that throughout the
first two thirds of the zoho arc
oda does a wonderful job of creating the
impression that rhizo
is really not here and the jack is
either operating based on wrong
information
or simply enjoys tormenting the minks
or maybe both the conviction with which
the minks lie
and denounce the samurai in front of the
beast pirates is
portrayed quite convincingly i think and
so
the wow effect that is wonderfully
reflected in the straw hat's reaction
really increases the emotional impact of
the twist
significantly seeing the likes of zorro
and luffy
both of whom have pulled quite similar
moves before as well
genuinely shocked and moved by this
really drives this moment home for me in
my opinion this is actually the best
plot twist in
all of one piece besides maybe the
reveal of cp-9 on water 7.
and that had less of an emotional impact
and more of a shock reaction
and beside all that i personally feel
like the anime did an
exceptional job with this scene as well
especially after the disaster of
dressrosa
in the manga the double spread with the
minks kneeling and nekomamushin in
arashi showing their relief at kinemon's
arrival
really got me and reading the chapter
packed quite a punch
but this is one of these moments where
music
dialogue and the visuals have the
potential to
amplify the scene even more and in this
case the animators did a great job of
representing
all of this i think the original
soundtrack made
especially for this scene in particular
is just
great even just hearing it outside of
the scene gives me goosebumps
and you can tell that it was tailored
directly to this scene
because it works just perfectly
this combined with perfectly timed
silences
and the individual close-ups of the
straw hats and the minks
make for a very emotional viewing
experience
that actually started a sort of positive
trend in regards to the anime for me
that i had found quite disappointing
during previous arcs
and going away from the emotional impact
of the scene
oda also integrates quite a bit of world
building
and characterization into the riser
reveal it gives us a much completer
picture of wano
and its structures for the very first
time for instance we learned about
kozuki odin
one of the most badass characters in the
entire story
that travel together with both
whitebeard and roger
with whom he even set foot on the
legendary island of love tale
we learn of his death and of momo's true
identity as the heir and leader of the
scabbards
and we finally meet rhizo and not only
do we get to know the person who the
mink suffered
so much for but we also learn about the
existence of the road poneglyphs as the
signpost to love tale itself
in general the rhizome moment forms the
center of one of my favorite arcs
zou is admittedly quite short but very
powerful
in terms of both storytelling and world
building
up to this point throughout the new
world from fisherman island until
dressrosa
there was a bit of a lack of focus on
the straw hats as a crew
and the arcs were also quite lengthy
with zou we get a ton of great straw hat
moments
and the setup for the next arc that is
solely focused around crew internal
struggles
it's short and straight to the point but
full to the brim with information
and story beats and so no matter how
strong one piece will undoubtedly get in
the new world until we reach love tale
ryzo is safe will always stay
one of the most iconic moments after
time skip
and to keep the ball rolling the next
iconic moment i want to talk about
is this one here
in my humble opinion corazon's character
and his sacrifice for law
are dramatically underrated and so we'll
be looking at that in the next video
thanks guys peace